first human trials of a corona virus
vaccine in Europe are taking place right
now in Britain this is a significant
step with several countries racing to
find ways to fight the illness now
blamed for more than a hundred and
ninety one thousand deaths worldwide MTS
tyub looks at the highly anticipated new
study it may just be one small shot but
it's possibly one giant leap in the
fight against the corona virus in
Britain elisa Granato is the first
volunteer in the world to receive this
potential vaccine I'm a scientist so of
course I want to try and support science
the scientific process whenever I can
human trials like this would normally
take years to develop
but has been achieved in just three
months by the experienced team of
scientists at Oxford University who say
not only does this vaccine have an
eighty percent chance of being effective
it could also be ready for use as early
as September I have a high degree of
confidence about this vaccine because
it's technology that I've used before of
course we have to test it but until a
vaccine is found countries desperate to
reopen their economies may look to
Sweden the Scandinavian nation has kept
its schools and businesses open to help
the general population build immunity a
goal they believe there within weeks of
still more than two thousand people have
died there which is hundreds more than
neighbouring countries with tighter
controls we are not telling people to
stay indoors I think that's a very
important part of our policy back in
Oxford and scientists concede the only
way they'll know for sure if their
vaccine is a success is if lots of
volunteers are exposed to the
coronavirus but with the UK still under
strict lockdown the irony is you need to
go somewhere like Sweden to do that
procedure yes this morning in PS Hiab
London